JOKE, GAYLE.
>> WE DO.
>>> WELCOME TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
AS WE BEGIN, WE'RE HEADING INTO
THE WEEKEND, THINGS ARE LOOKING
UP IN THE NATION'S FIGHT AGAINST
THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE U.S. JUST RECORDED ITS
LOWEST DAILY CASE NUMBER IN
SEVEN MONTHS AFTER WEEKS OF
STEADY DECLINE.
57% OF ADULTS IN THIS COUNTRY
HAVE GOTTEN AT LEAST ONE SHOT OF
A COVID VACCINE, AND PFIZER HAS
APPLIED FOR KIDS AS YOUNG AS 12
TO GET ITS VACCINE VERY SOON.
CARTER EVANS JOINS US FROM SANTA
MONICA, CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
A FEW MONTHS AGO, CALIFORNIA WAS
IN DEEP, DEEP TROUBLE.
>> Reporter: IT SURE WAS.
CALIFORNIA WENT FROM MORE THAN
16,000 CASES A DAY TO JUST A FEW
HUNDRED.
HERE IN LOS ANGELES, WE'RE IN
THE YELLOW TIER OF COVID
RESTRICTION, AND THAT MEANS
CAPACITY CAN EXPAND AT SOME
BUSINESSES.
IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR MANY BARS TO
OPEN THEIR DOORS FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE LAST YEAR.
♪
>> GOOD TO SEE EVERYBODY.
>> Reporter: IT'S A NEW DAY IN
LOS ANGELES.
NOW UNDER FEWER COVID
RESTRICTIONS THAN EVER BEFORE,
ALLOWING BIGGER CROWDS AT
ANNOUNCEMENT PARKS AND MORE
PEOPLE IN MOVIE THEATERS.
>> THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME OUT.
SO WHERE DO WE COME?
>> Reporter: A RELIEF FOR ABLE
RAMIREZ WHO HAD TO LAY OFF 63
PEOPLE FROM HIS TWO RESTAURANTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
DO YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF LUCKY
TO HAVE SURVIVED THIS LONG?
>> CONSIDER MYSELF LUCKY AND
BLESSED.
PEOPLE SAY, THANK GOD YOU ARE
OPEN.
I SAY, NO, THANK YOU GOD YOU ARE
HERE.
>> Reporter: THE RULES RELAX
LIMITS ON INDOOR FITNESS CLASSES
AND VENUES LIKE THE CHURCH OF
EIGHT WHEELS IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THE CITY BY THE BAY IS ROLLING
TOWARD HERD IMMUNITY.
NEARLY THREE-FOURTHS OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S VACCINE-ELIGIBLE
POPULATION HAS AT LEAST ONE
SHOT.
NATIONWIDE THAT NUMBER IS NOW
57%.
AND WITH VACCINATIONS CLIMBING,
RESTRICTIONS ARE FALLING.
NEW YORK WILL ELIMINATE CAPACITY
LIMITS ON MOST BUSINESSES
EFFECTIVE MAY 19th.
BROADWAY TICKETS ARE ON SALE
AGAIN.
AND IN ILLINOIS, THE STATE'S
BRIDGE PHASE TAKES EFFECT NEXT
WEEK.
>> FOR RESTAURANTS AND BARS AND
RETAIL AND WEDDINGS AND PUBLIC
GATHERINGS, THIS MEANS HIGHER
CAPACITY LIMITS AND A VERY
HOPEFUL MOVE TOWARD FULL
REOPENING.
>> Reporter: WITH SOME OF THE
LAST HOLDOUTS MOVING TOWARD
REOPENING, IT'S A WELCOME SIGN
FOR AMERICANS CRAVING A RETURN
TO NORMALCY.
BUT IT'S STILL TOO SOON TO
DECLARE VICTORY, WARNS
INFECTIOUS DISEASE EXPERT DR.
MICHAELGO. MANY PEOPLE ARE --
ACCESSIBLE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTING --
[ NO AUDIO ]
THE WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION
WILL ULTIMATELY MAKE THE
DECISION.
PHARMACEUTICAL GIANTS HERE IN
THE U.S. SAY THEY WORRY ABOUT
THE QUALITY AND SAFETY OF
VACCINE PRODUCTION.
YOU SEE, IT'S NOT CLEAR YET
EXACTLY HOW THIS IS GOING TO
AFFECT THOSE PHARMACEUTICA